we should talk a little more about
Newton's third law because there are
some deep misconceptions that many
people have about this law it seems
simple but it's not nearly as simple as
you might think so people often phrase
it as for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction but that's just
way too vague to be useful so a version
that's a little better says that for
every force
there's an equal and opposite force so
this is a little better the equal sign
means that these forces are equal in
magnitude and this negative sign means
that they're just different by the
direction of the vector so these are
vectors so this says that this pink
vector F has the opposite direction but
equal in magnitude to this green vector
F but to show you why this is still a
little bit too vague consider this if
this is all you knew about Newton's
third law that for every force there's
an equal and opposite force you might
wonder if you were clever you might be
like wait a minute
if if for every force F right there's
got to be a force that's equal and
opposite well why doesn't that just mean
that every force in the universe cancels
shouldn't every force just cancel then
at that point doesn't that just mean
that there's no acceleration that's even
possible
because if I go exert a force F on
something if there's going to be a force
negative F doesn't that mean that no
matter what force I put forward it's
just going to get cancelled and the
answer is no and the reason it's no is
because these two forces are exerted on
different objects so you have to be
careful so the reason I say that this
statement of Newton's third law is still
a little bit too vague is because this
is really on different objects so if
this is the force on object a exerted by
object B then this force over here has
to be the force on object B exerted by
object a in other words these forces
down here are exerted on different
objects I'm going to move this over to
the side I'm going to move this over to
here let's draw two different objects to
show explicitly what I mean so if there
was some object a so put some object a
in here I'm going to make sure there's
an object a let's say this is object a
and it had this green force exerted on
it F so this object right here is a well
there's going to be another object
object B we'll just make it another
circle so we'll make it look like this
so here's object B and it's going to
have this pink force F negative F
exerted on it so I'm going to call this
object B now we're okay now we know
these forces can't cancel and the reason
these forces can't cancel is because
they're on two different objects but
when you just say Newton's third law is
that every force has an equal knops
force it's not clear that it has to be
on different objects but it does have to
be on different objects
so these Newton force law pairs
oftentimes these are called force pairs
or Newton's third law partner forces are
always on different objects so the
convention I'm using is that the first
letter represents the force the object
that the force is on excuse me so this a
represents that this force F this green
force F is on a and it's good it's
exerted by D and this shows that it's
exerted on B because the first letter is
on the first one and it's exerted by the
second object a so this pink force
exerted is exerted on be this green
force is exerted on a they're equal and
opposite they do not cancel they cannot
cancel because they're not on the same
object so that's why these don't cancel
and they are the same magnitude even if
the two objects are not the same size
this is another misconception if object
a is a planet a big planet or maybe a
star this is yellow so it looks like a
star let's say this is some big star and
this is some smaller planet orbiting
that star this is not to scale unless
this planet was enormous so this is some
planet but this planet could be hundreds
thousands of times millions of times
less massive than the star but it would
still exert the same force so if this
star is pulling on the planet with this
pink force F negative F then this planet
has to be pulling on the star with this
green force F and they have to have the
same magnitude even if they are
different sizes so people quote Newton's
third law but sometimes they don't
really believe it
if I told you this planet was a million
times less massive than the star people
would want to say that well then the
star obviously pulls more on the planet
than the planet pulls on the star but
that's not true according to Newton's
third law and Newton's third law says
they have to be the same even if they're
different sizes so if this was the earth
and this is the Moon the earth pulls on
the moon just as much as the moon pulls
on the earth and you might still object
you might say wait a minute that makes
no sense
I know the star just basically sits
there and the planet gets whipped around
in a circle
how come this plan is getting whipped
around and the stars just staying put
that's because just because the forces
are equal that doesn't mean the result
is equal in other words the forces could
be equal but the accelerations don't
have to be equal the acceleration is
going to be the net force divided by the
mass so even if the force is the same
you divide by that mass you'll get a
different acceleration and that's why
the result of the force does not have to
be the same even though the forces do
have to be the same because of Newton's
third law another misconception people
sometimes make is they think there might
be a delay in the creation of this
Newton's third law partner force and
people think maybe if I exert this first
force fast enough I can catch the
universe sleeping and there might be
some sort of delay in the creation of
this other force but that's not true
Newton's third law is universal no
matter what the situation no matter what
the acceleration or non acceleration or
motion or no motion whether one objects
bigger or smaller if they're Newton's
third law partner forces they are equal
they are opposite and they are always
equal and opposite at every given moment
in time so even if I came in all
guns-a-blazing Chuck Norris style trying
to dropkick some wall that does not look
like the correct form for a dropkick but
even if I came in flying at this wall as
soon as I start to make contact with the
wall I'm going to exert a force on the
wall and the wall has to exert a force
back so I'd exert a force on the wall to
the right and this would be the force on
the wall by my foot there'd have to be
an equal and opposite force instantly
transmitted backwards on my foot this
would be the force on my foot by the
wall and this happens instantaneously
there is no delay you can't kick this
wall fast enough for this other force to
not be generated instantaneously as soon
as your foot starts to exert any force
on the wall whatsoever
the wall is going to start exerting that
same force back on your foot so Newton's
third law is universal but people still
have trouble identifying these third law
partner forces so one of the best ways
to do it is by listing both objects as
soon as you list both objects well to
figure out where the partner force is
you can just reverse these labels so I
know over here if one of my forces is
the force on the wall by my foot to find
the partner force to this force I can
just reverse the labels and say it's got
to be the force on my foot by the wall
which I drew over here so this is a
great way to identify the third law
partner forces because it's not always
obvious what force is the partner force
so to show you how this can be tricky
consider this example say we've got the
ground and a table so this example
drives people crazy for some reason if
I've got a box sitting on a table we'll
call it box a box a is going to have
forces exerted on it one of those forces
is going to be the gravitational force
so the force of gravity is going to pull
straight down on box a and if I were to
ask you what force is the third law
partner force to this force of gravity
I'm willing to bet a lot of people might
say well there's an upwards force on box
a exerted by the table and that's true
and if this box a is just sitting here
not accelerating these two forces are
going to be equal and opposite so it's
even more tempting to say that these two
forces are equal and opposite because of
the third law but that's not true these
two forces are equal and opposite
because of the second law the second law
says if there's no acceleration then the
net force has to be zero the forces have
to cancel and that's what's happening
here these forces are equal and opposite
they're cancelling on box a which is a
way to know that they are not third law
partner forces because third law partner
forces are so always exerted on
different objects they can never cancel
if their third law partner forces so
what's going on over here we've got two
forces that are cancelling they're equal
and opposite but they're not third law
partner forces their partner forces are
somewhere else I haven't drawn their
partner forces yet so let's try to
figure out what their partner forces are
so let's get
rid of this let's come back to here
let's slow it down to figure out what
the partner forces named the two objects
interacting so this force of gravity
I shouldn't be vague I should call it
the force on object a our box a exerted
by well you can't just say gravity
gravity's not an object so the object
that is exerting this gravitational
force on a is the earth so this force
really this gravitational force if I
want to be careful is the force on
object a exerted by the earth now it's
easy to figure out where the partner
force is the partner force can be found
just by reversing these labels so
instead of the force on a by the earth
there's got to be an equal opposite
force which is the force on the earth by
box a so opposite means it has to point
up so that's to be an upward force and
that upward force has to be exerted on
the earth by box a and this is kind of
weird because you may not have realized
it but if the earth is pulling down on a
box or u that means you are pulling up
on the earth and this might seem
ridiculous I mean if you jump up you
jump up you fall back down you move
around but the earth just sits there if
your forces are equal how come the earth
doesn't move around like you do and
again is because just because the forces
are the same the acceleration doesn't
have to be the same the mass of the
earth is so big compared to your mass
there's basically no acceleration even
though the forces on you and the forces
on the earth are the same so these two
are third law partner forces these two
are joined together forever they have to
be equal no matter what happens these
two forces will always be equal I don't
care if this box is accelerating or not
accelerating whether there's motion or
no motion whether it's hitting a wall or
sitting on a table falling through space
these two forces must always be equal
and opposite because of the third law so
how about this other force this force
that the table was exerting so this is
the force on a by the table so if I want
to label it correctly I call it the
force on Box a exerted by the table now
finding the third law partner force is
easy I can just reverse these labels and
I get that there must be instead of an
upward force a downward force on the
table by a so I'm gonna have another
force here on the table it's going to be
a downward force
downward force on the table by a that's
the third law partner force to this
upward force that the table is exerting
these two forces are also third law
partner forces these forces are going to
be equal and opposite no matter what
happens this force on box a by the table
and this force on the table by a box a
must be equal no matter what happens but
the force on box a by the table does not
have to be equal and opposite to the
force on a by the earth it happens to be
equal and opposite in a case where
there's no acceleration but if we stuck
this whole situation into an elevator or
a rocket that had some huge acceleration
upwards even if there's acceleration
upwards these partner forces have to be
equal so the force on a by the table and
the force on the table by a will have to
be equal similarly the force on the
earth by a and the force on a by the
earth have to be equal but no longer
will these two forces have to be equal
because they're not partner forces they
might be equal and opposite in some
circumstances but they don't always have
to be equal and opposite if we're
accelerating upwards this upward force
on the Box must be bigger than the
downward force on the box and so these
won't be equal recapping quickly
Newton's third law is a statement about
the forces on two different objects and
because it's about two different objects
those forces can never cancel to find
the Newton's third law partner force
just reverse the label after you've
identified the two objects that are
interacting the third law partner forces
have to be equal in magnitude even if
one object is larger than the other or
has more charge or any property that
might consume like it would convey more
force than another object if those are
the two objects interacting the forces
must be of equal magnitude in opposite
directions the forces instantaneously
generated this partner forces and be
careful some forces might seem like
partner forces and they might be equal
and opposite but they're not necessarily
third law partner forces it may just be
equal and opposite for other reasons